To set up the IK3 bone function, we're going to need two new controls, one for the foot
and one for the pole vector, and tell the function which bones we want to affect.
Let's give ourselves a little bit more space here and search for the IK3 bone function.
Now you can see that this function takes a lot of information in, which is predominantly
about the axes of our bones, a pole vector node, and then the bones that we're trying
to affect along with a foot control.
We're not going to create a thigh control today because a foot control will be all we
need.
So the first thing we're going to do is figure out our primary and our secondary axes.
So if we hover over the function, we can see that the primary axis is the axis pointing
down the bone, which is typically X, and the secondary axis is our up axis, which is
typically Z, or sometimes none.
So I pop these open.
To figure this out, what we can do if I come to character and bones, then all hierarchy,
we'll be able to see all the bones in the viewport here.
And the bones that we want to affect will be sort of the upper thigh, lower thigh, the
lower leg, and a foot down here.
So if I select that from the viewport, we can see that's our leg FR01L.
And to see the orientation axes on this, if you come up to the option box at the top and
choose display axes on selection, this is not usually turned on by default, so you should
have to turn that on.
And then if we zoom right into that control, the bones, sorry, we can see that the Z axis,
the X axis is pointing along our bone, and the Z axis is the one that's pointing up.
So our primary axis is pointing along the bone, that's X, and secondary axis will change
that to be Z.
Now we don't have any all vector node yet, and we don't have a foot control.
But what we do have are the bones in the chain.
And if we pop each one of these open, we can actually fill this information in now.
So bone A is going to be the most, the uppermost bone in our chain, which is going to be the
leg FR01L.
So with that selected, we can hit this little arrow and fill that information in there.
And then just go down the chain and add each of those.
And if I find O4, the foot base just here, we can plug that in as well.
So leg 01, 02, 03, and 04, that represents the chain of our leg.
Now that we have our bone information set up, we can create the foot control.
And we're going to do that based off of the leg 04 bone.
So if I browse to that, I can right click, go to New, Control.
And down the bottom here, you'll see we've got New, Control with the same name, just
out of the hierarchy of the skeleton.
And we'll customize the look of this again.
So I'll make this a box, and I will just scale it up a little.
Maybe that's a bit too big.
And so it's not quite so awkward to animate with.
What I'm going to do under the offset heading here is reset the rotation of the Y channel,
or the Y axis, to zero.
Just so that if we were to translate this up and down, or move it forwards and backwards,
it's just easier to animate within that sense.
And now we can put the information into our IK3 bone function.
So we're going to do a little bit of math to make sure that we get this control in the
right location, to make sure that it's on the same plane as the leg joints.
Luckily, there is a function that already exists to help us do this.
So what I'm going to do, if I just drag this out here, give us more space again, right-click,
search for compute pole vector.
Now this is going to ask us for the three bones that we want to use as our plane to
create the pole vector's location from.
And the output transforms are going to give us that location.
So first of all, we need to create a new control.
So if I right-click in a blank space, select new control, and just rename this leg underscore
pv underscore ctrl.
So this is going to be a leg pole vector control.
I'll just change this so we can see it more easily in the viewport, to a sort of green
sort of color.
And I think what we'll probably do is just scale that up to maybe five, for example.
So this is our new control.
But again, it's not in the correct location.
So we need to feed this compute pole vector function the three bones that we want to use
to calculate its position.
And that's going to be our fr02, 03, and 04.
So if I plug in 02, plug in 03, and then plug in 04, that's sort of our thigh, knee, and foot
bones.
And if I then connect up that logic, what we'll do is use this transform information to set
the position of this pole vector control.
So I'm going to drag that into our rig graph and choose set control, connect up the logic,
and connect up the transform pin to the value pin.
And you can see that positions our pole vector control along the plane of those three bones
and we know that it's perfectly aligned.
One thing that I'm going to do is just increase this offset factor value so that we're a little
further away from the mesh.
And it means it's easier not to get lost inside the mesh.
Now we don't want this running all the time because if we're setting the transform of
our control, we won't be able to move this and animate it.
So if we right click the control where it is now and choose set offset transform from
current.
That sets its new sort of zero pose like freezing transforms in mayor.
So we can now delete this small bit of logic, compile, and we'll see that this pole vector
control is now positioned in the world along the plane of those three bones.
So now if we were to grab that, input that into our IK3 bone, we can then connect up
the logic.
And those are small pop there, but that's something we can fix.
But we now have control using the pole vector over where that knee is pointing.
And we also have the foot control, which means that we can move this round and place it wherever
we need to.
And then tie leg is reacting and automatically moving where it needs to.
Now that small pop is just due to the fact that we're actually allowing the bones to stretch
to 1.5 their original length.
So if we set that back down to 1, that'll fix that and bring those bones back in line.
So we now have the rig set up with the rotator controls for the gun and for the gun body,
as well as our IK leg setup using the IK3 bone function.
The next thing we're going to look at is a little bit more exciting.
We're going to take a look at the piston function so that whenever we're moving these, the legs
around, you can see the pistons inside here just underneath.
We'll make sure that they're functioning properly and always pointing towards one another and
not deforming in the strange way that they are now.